is bitcoin bad for the environment the  short answer is no it doesn't have to be  bitcoin can be mined from anywhere in  the world because of its decentralized  nature this means miners can use wasted  energy from anywhere in the world and  since the energy is wasted naturally  it's better for the environment here's  the thing since it is wasted energy it's  going to be cheaper which means miners  are financially incentivized to seek out  cheaper energy this is known as energy  arbitrage also you can mine bitcoin  using renewable energy like solar or  geothermal giving off zero co2 emissions  bitcoin is better for the environment  because for the very first time energy  can be sourced from anywhere in the  world